BECAUSE THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
THEY ARE DOING.
JOE CONCHA COVERS MEDIA FOR
THE HILL AND HE JOINS US
TONIGHT.
JOY, DO YOU THINK THAT
JOE, DO YOU THINK THAT
THE REAL PROBLEM WITH
BUZZFEED GIVEN SEGMENTS TO
THIS WHERE MEAN COMMENTATORS
ON FOX NEWS GIVE SEGUE TO
STORIES LIKE THIS.
>> LET ME ADDRESS CHUCK TODD
THERE PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE.
THIS IS HE NOT ONLY THE
MODERATOR OF MEET THE PRESS.
HE IS ALSO THE POLITICAL
DIRECTOR OF NBC NEWS.
HERE'S THE THING.
EVERYBODY ALL THOSE ANCHORS
AND PUNDITS YOU JUST SHOW
HAD AMPLE WARNING THERE WAS
A SERIOUS PROBLEM WITH THIS
STORY.
ON FRIDAY MORNING, BEFORE
ALL THE IMPEACHED AND IF
TRUES CAME OUT.
AS YOU MENTIONED YOU HAD
ANTHONY COME YEA, ONE OF THE
AUTHORS IN THIS PIECE ON CNN
SAYING HE HADN'T SEEN THE
EVIDENCE THAT WAS USED AS A
FOUNDATION FOR THE STORY.
THEN MINUTES LATER ON MSNBC
THE OTHER AUTHOR SAID HE HAD
SEEN THE EVIDENCE.
THAT IS YOUR RED FLAG RIGHT
THERE WHERE CHUCK TODD AS A
POLITICAL DIRECTOR THEN
NEEDS TO GET THE TROOPS
TOGETHER AND SAY GUYS, LOOK,
OUR ONUS ORGANIZATION, NBC
NEWS COULD NOT VERIFY THIS
REPORT INDEPENDENTLY AND
THEREFORE WE SHOULD GO ABOUT
THIS WITH EXTREME CAUTION.
INSTEAD, YOU MENTIONED THE
NUMBER, NEARLY 200 TIMES.
ON NBC ALONE THE WORD
IMPEACH OR IMPEACHMENT WAS
SAID 97 TIMES.
THAT FALLS AT CHUCK TODD'S
FEET AS A POLITICAL DIRECTOR
WHEN IN THE MORNING
EDITORIAL MEETING HE SHOULD
HAVE MADE SURE THAT DIDN'T
HAPPEN.
ON CNN SAME THING.
THEY DIDN'T VERIFY THE
REPORT INDEPENDENTLY AND IT
WAS SAID ON THERE 82 TIMES.
NOW, LOOK, WHERE ARE WE AT
NOW?
JASON LEOPOLD, THE OTHER
REPORTER IN THE STORY SAID
HE SAW THE EVIDENCE IS LIKE
EDWARD SNOWDEN.
YOU CAN'T FIND HIM.
HE HASN'T TWEETED FOR THREE
DAYS HASN'T WRITTEN ANY
TWEETS ANYWAY AND HE ISN'T
DOING ANY INTERVIEWS.
YOU SEE --
>> Tucker: MAY I CLARIFY?
SO, ALWAYS STRUCK ME AS A
REAL REPORTER JUST TO BE
HONEST ABOUT IT BUT IT
LEOPOLD KID HAS LIKE A LONG
HISTORY OF REALLY RECKLESS
BEHAVIOR.
HE IS THE ONE WHO PUBLICLY
REPORTED AND TURNED OUT TO
BE FALSE THAT KARL ROVE HAD
BEEN INDICTED.
HE WAS FIRED FOR PLAGIARISM.
THE GUY IS A POLITICAL
ACTIVIST.
WHY WOULD YOU EVER PUT
SOMEONE LIKE THAT ON A STORY
OF THIS MAGNITUDE?
>> PRECISELY.
AND IT'S FUNNY BECAUSE WITH
LEOPOLD AND SO MANY IN THE
MEDIA, THE MISTAKES ONLY
SEEM TO GO ONE WAY TOWARD
REPUBLICANS OR CONSERVATIVES
OR TRUMP IN THIS CASE.
I MEAN, ASK YOURSELF THIS
QUESTION.
WHEN WAS THE LAST TIME YOU
SAW A MAJOR MEDIA OUTLET
MAKE A MISTAKE OR A MAJOR
ERROR IN A STORY ABOUT A
DEMOCRATIC LAWMAKER?
YOU KNOW, I'M RACKING MY
BRAIN.
>> Tucker: THAT'S SUCH A
GOOD POINT.
>> Tucker: BEEN WATCHING FOR
30 YEARS NEVER SEEN THAT
HAPPEN NOT ONE TIME.
WILL YOU KEEP A LIST?
I WANT TO BE HONEST ABOUT
IT.
YOU KNOW, IF YOU SEE NANCY
PELOSI UNFAIRLY IMPOUND BY
CHUCK TODD WILL YOU LET ME
KNOW AND WE WILL DO A
SEGMENT ON IT.
>> I WILL BE ALL OVER IT BY
THE WAY GLEN GREENAWALT HAS
A GREAT PIECE TODAY IN THE
INTERCEPT.
HE LISTS 10 MAJOR STORIES
THAT THE MEDIA HAS GOTTEN
WRONG ON RUSSIA.
THIS ISN'T A ONE OFF
BETRAYED BY SOMEONE JUST AN
EXCUSE TO ATTACK THE MEDIA.
WE HAVE SEEN THIS OVER AND
OVER AND OVER AGAIN AND AS I